foreign
try not to laugh try not to laugh you
might [__] yourself but try I don't eat
flour I don't eat a lot of sugar anymore
not hardly any sugar I I'm a food addict
so I had to give up foods you look great
thank you so much oh she looks fantastic
oh my God lost a lot of I mean you know
I used to be a house this is the kind of
thing where people know you're a condo
now you're a townhouse
you're a pool house now
now I'm a cabana
that is the funniest thing I've heard in
a long time well it's tough because I
you know I have a young stepson like a
teenaged stepson who's you know starting
to talk to girls you know like whatever
you navigate that it's tough because you
don't really know how to tell him like
what's okay and what's not other than
I'm like hey just you know be nice to
girls look them in the eye you know like
say hi like you know but it's like you
don't know even that I swear to God I
said to my stepson I was like you know
you're talking and girls like yeah like
a couple of girls and I was like oh good
I was like do you talk to them and he
was like yeah I said what do you open up
with and he was like well you know like
it's tough he's like because the one
girl I like I swear he said he goes to
one girl I like doesn't identify as a
girl yeah so she's a girl I know she's a
girl but she doesn't like to be called
that so I don't know what to see because
I don't know like how I'm supposed to
talk to her and I was like freak well I
said you know what you're ready I said I
you're gonna have to talk to your real
father about that
your stepdad yeah yeah I can't live
without putting a Q-tip in my ear you
put it in every day if I don't have a
Q-tip to put my ear I can't live but how
much wax are you building up each day
that you have to it's not about the wax
because I was like I'm doing it every
day so there kind of is no wax buildup
it's like a mental first of all I love
the feeling my ear is itchy sometimes so
I love the feeling and second of all I
get the water out of my ears by doing it
as well you know what it's nice because
we're as men we always penetrate today
it's nice to be penetrated once in a
while yeah you're not you don't have to
do a full gay sex it always depends on
it depends on the whole but penetration
in some holes that are not sexually in
nature can be nice a penetration in a
non-sexual hole all day people ask me
all the time Chris why do you pick your
nose every day I said because I want to
be penetrated but I'm not gay but I
still do want to feel what it's like to
be inside my hall and that's what I do
that and that's how you deal with the QT
that's great pimp has something to say
yes Harvard Health says do not clean
your ears they're self-cleaning I know I
know what Harvard's Health says but well
listen I can't Harvard Health that I
didn't know my ears were a [__]
Roomba yeah
[Laughter]
when you were done talking I was gonna
say oh we should have said it right at
the same time tell the truth how's it
doing I want to look at the special it
was on trending now but I don't know if
it is anymore Chris DiStefano the
special
okay first of all out of the 64 votes on
IMDb 8 out of 10 pretty [__] good
that's not bad that's really good yeah I
think we're not gonna get a 10 out of
10. well you could no that's impossible
yeah and here's the first and let me see
the first critic review all right here
you go Krista Stefano especially where
she is unbelievable I came 17 times this
guy is a mega babe wow what a pipe on
this tardo it's a little more than a
half hour it's engaging and funny and
boy oh boy do I like to come his other
special 38 waist also made me come not
as much as this in fact estefano was set
to release especially when she on
YouTube but since no one can come as
much on YouTube as they do on Netflix he
decided this is the best place to
feature it wow it's my dad
I don't understand
Chris I was watching on daytime
television you Wendy Cummings and two
other women talk about female body image
and you are curled up in a ball like no
one look at me or ask me any question I
so what happened was with that is I got
booked I think the very first one was
was when Whitney Cummings was filling in
for uh Wendy Williams she asked me to
come on her show and you know be a guest
and then I I had like you know before
the show the hair and makeup guy was
like you know like this really like
flamboyant gay guy he was like you're
gonna have so much fun you could be
great this could be good and then like
you know I'll be like right here I'll
take your makeup off
your daughter hurts like he was just
like crazy and we were having a good
time incredible yeah yeah and then and
he was like Whispering he was so good
positive energy and then I went out
there and I just started swinging for
the fences with jokes
Chris the way people react to you just
look at the ground they don't even know
what to do and the look on your face is
like am I gonna get away with it it was
like a 10 o'clock in the morning this TV
audience so everybody else is doing like
knock-knock jokes and like Michelle buto
is up there being like yeah like a
politician like girl power like that
like everyone's clapping and then I'm
just out there doing jokes about how
like I wish Travis Barker would die in a
plane crash and then they're like and
they're like wait what and then and put
it their jokes and then just and then
I'm doing like Confederate like Civil
War jokes and they're like what is
happening and I'm doing abortion jokes
with Whitney Cummings and they're all
like bombing like so bad but then and
then when I go off the set that like a
guy who was like yeah everybody left my
green room was vacant nobody was there
like no they didn't even give me a car
home they're like you can get on the
train
and so and and I then after that me and
homeless Pimp My Guy Michael I've been
homeless pimp who does all my production
stuff he was like dude because I was
like dude I just bombed so hard on
daytime TV he's like we have to get the
footage and we watch the footage and we
were on the floor like dying like to the
point where I almost burst my appendix
from because we were dying left on how
hard I was bombing and I was like you
know what clip it I was like put all
that stuff out because I remember that
night Michelle buteau called me and she
was like it's gonna be okay sweetie
don't even worry about it I was like
lady I'm not looking to be a daytime
television [__] host I went with the
intention of being a comic so I went on
so I went on and and so I I edited it
and I put it out there and it got like a
decent amount of traction I was like oh
Chrissy Day times I'll come bomb on your
show and then I started going on all
these daytime shows and just be like I'm
gonna do the jokes as if this was late
night as if this was two o'clock in the
morning at the comedy seller that's I'm
approaching this show so why you guys
would have a man on this panel this is
the worst idea ever because I'm gonna
say anything I say the audience is going
to hate me if I was Travis Barker Travis
where's my if you're watching and I know
that you are you should scan your body
right now and make sure that there are
no other tattoos of any other women on
your body because it's not going to be
cover up next time she's going to start
amputating body parts and you're going
to come out to your next concert looking
like a Civil War veteran so you really
need to be careful wait a minute
the comedy I was like my knees hurt from
tap dancing take the tap shoes bag I
want to sit down relax keep calling
stand-up comedy I'm gonna sit down and
do comedy I'm tired y'all stop asking us
to do stuff okay he needs her too but
I got it
I love that I'm bombing on the show I
love it
I keep forgetting it's daytime TV it's
not our podcast TT Jerry's coming I
clean the pool this morning the tiger
shark 1400 what do you guys know about
it dude it's crazy yeah then this is not
garbage this place is beautiful this is
unbelievable it's okay it is it is it is
a beautiful place but there's got to be
something garbage in here
you bought a house not knowing anything
yeah
yeah okay this has real like lottery
winner Vibes like you're not gonna be
I'm not going to be here in three years
and someone's going to tragically die
can they repo a house well you know
funny because I don't know first of all
first of all I I get I've been getting
scammed by everybody I come in here
they're like oh you need you need bee
spray because there was a b back there
200 there yeah you need a Johnson flange
or something all that stuff I go to you
know the pool I put chlorine tablets in
pool I'm like we'll go with chlorine we
got the pool guy over because no no the
pH is off so he puts chemicals in the
heater explodes
corroded the heater pipes and the valves
and this that long story short it's two
grand for a heater I could sell them
directly to you so we buy a [__]
heater yeah he's like listen I got one
on the truck
so I got lit up at the heater he said
the pool will be at 90 degrees the way
my family likes it back in Puerto Rico
it'll be warm water I just stuck my the
heater's been on for for 10 hours just
stuck my finger in it it's 73 degrees so
she's like the pool's heated I'm like I
don't know if it's running buddy yeah I
love that by the way I knew something
three years into it and then forgot it
for 10 years until I got on Joe Rogan
and all of a sudden I [__] remembered
all this gems [__] when I'm flying
home from his podcast I'm like oh I had
the story that could have changed my
life and I didn't say it I had my
machine I said I waited to do it on hey
babe and Sal wasn't even there
[Music]
intermittent fasting but then I think I
think the glasses and the watches from
the fasting so well it's a full glow up
you're doing the body glow up too yeah
and Jazz and my girlfriend hates it
she's like what you know what she hated
because she's like you know you eat
glasses to watch the body what the [__]
are you doing she doesn't like it I was
like I'm trying to be healthy babe I
want to keep you fat she wants to keep
me fat wow yeah she wants to keep me fat
and I told you sure
honor Maybe not maybe she's just doesn't
want to put pressure on you yeah she's
worried if you're going crazy with all
the watch and the glasses and the fat
that you you might snap well she gets
worried about me because I go I go
harder go home and she's like you you go
too fast with things she goes you go
from zero to 100 and I just worry that
you've lost all this weight in this good
period quick period of time and I just
worry that there's a you know you go too
hard and then something else happens
because she reminded me she's like
remember the last time you lost all this
weight this quick it was 2018 and I said
yeah and she's like and then remember
all of 2019 you thought you were gay
winning by the way you versus your
sexuality uh so far right now it's right
now it's me but we are wavering where
it's one of those things where when I
hit 40 if I'm lucky enough to hit 40
there might just be a thing where I'm
like listen I gotta be honest with you
the most fun I've had I don't know if
you haven't seen the show please Google
It season one of White Lotus the under
do you see white lotion I've seen
episode one okay so the first season of
White Lotus the the best character is
this Australian gay guy yeah the manager
that's the guy I want to be that's
that's the guy who's like that I love
that guy and it's like what is that guy
doing he's just being gay he's just
having fun yep you know I'm like and I I
found myself identifying with that guy I
was like I don't know that I can eat a
guy's ass over a table which is one of
the scenes but I'm like you know what
dude can you I can be gay without
hooking up with a guy she's been hit
right
yeah yeah
you look like a like
what do people say you look like like
you almost look like you know how like
some humans like you can just tell
they're like bread from like Neanderthal
that's who you are
just big [__] guy like you're the guy
who in medieval times you with an ax I
100 would throw my wife and children in
front of me and say kill them but
I literally I literally you come at me
with an ax I'm on my knees ready to suck
everyone's [__] oh the chieftain
stomach I would not be able to do it
you're so big how big is he can you
stand up I mean are you tall too
terrified he even put his toes away
toes aren't like that you're way too big
dude and with that here's the thing with
as tall as you are and as big as you are
this is just the way God works there's
no way you have a high IQ there's no
[__] shot at hell you're not going
she's like 100 right here oh is he smart
what school does he go to
UNM
University of New Mexico so not smart
um just like I said I'm sorry I'm sorry
I didn't I was just kidding around you
know I'm just [__] around you you
know I'm just [__] you're not on a
steroid cycle right now right you got
rage you don't have any rage okay
how happy were you right when he right
because when you saw him I mean you were
like yes
because you look are you Native American
you have a Native American look you know
what I mean you're part Native America
Benny thanks many thanks I know it's
what it is you're like Sacagawea and
he's John Smith
that's what it is
Kimmy your [__] smallpox
and how old are you dude you're like 22
just a young [__] kid dude oh I love
it you're like Wreck-It Ralph I love it
do you also go to you so where did you
met her in New Mexico yeah nice dude why
are you here what are you guys doing
here
your brother's getting nice dude are you
gonna eat one of the groomsmen
what team
do you play sports
uh football yeah magic yeah I play chess
I'll do good for you man good got to
keep a beautiful couple I love it I love
it and diverse right Native American
white child good you guys are like a
[__] Community College brochure
six five six six
yeah
I know dude it's gonna be a lot of guys
going home and what guesses weight
six five two forty
what is it
285. oh my god dude there are I swear to
God thirty percent of the men in this
room have a chubby just know that
there's 30 some of the guys I see some
of the guys
yeah
86 5 285 dude you're so gifted I hope
you have a little dick what's his
problem
God has to give you you're [__] smart
you go to the University of New Mexico
one of our top universities where they
teach you all about breaking bad and
meth
foreign
beautiful girlfriend what's his problem
what's his flaw you have to know you're
his girlfriend how long have you guys
been going out
five years what's his flaw he's got to
have something
he's got a big dick then
does he have a big dick
pretty wow she just went like this
I feel like one it like that that's his
dick you know like
it's out he's like yeah dude I put I
have to put a shirt on my dick
because it's so big so
[Music]
and you're a good football player too
what position do you play
uh offensive tackles you're good
in division one oh wow you might like go
to the NFL and [__] oh my god dude
there's got to be a flaw what's this
what's your full name
what's your wait what's your first name
Adam and what's your last name okay Adam
gay
it always works Adam gay thank you good
[__] night sir good night happy pride
month to you Adam
foreign
[Music]